I demand another assistant oh come on is
another assistant all right I'll get
another system thank you no I want a
different assistant don't be silly
that's Eric Idle and Monty Python's
Flying Circus of course the legendary
comedy troupe which idol co-founded
celebrates its 50th anniversary next
year and idles just released his memoir
always look on the bright side of life a
title Python fans are very familiar with
we met up with him this week at the
Lambs Club here in New York ah good
morning I'd like to buy a book please I
will I'm afraid we don't have it I'm
sorry we don't have any books we're
fresh out of them good morning with
their irreverent often surreal sketches
Marty Python's Flying Circus would
change comedy well it certainly looks as
though we're in for a splendid afternoon
sport in this the one hundred and twenty
seventh of a class twit of the year show
they were very serious about it we took
it very very seriously it should be
funny the troupe featured five Brits
Eric Idle along with John Cleese and
Graham Chapman Michael Palin and Terry
Jones and American terry gilliam who did
the animation together they produced 45
television episodes five films and a
blockbuster Broadway musical this is the
Schubert we ran for almost 5 years your
mother was a hamster and your father
smelt of elderberries the film Monty
Python and the Holy Grail was adapted by
idle into Spamalot which premiered here
in 2005 do you remember opening night
very well I was right here the pie all
the pythons came we worried it all about
doing Python without any of the original
Python cast well it's interesting
because I always think of it the writing
that makes Python special that material
in the Grail is really really funny you
know I fast in your general direction
people still go to that same castle and
yell at everyday
you're wicked I know to me now to me
that's not I don't mean that's not
that's not say no more
it was Idol who wrote this memorable
Python sketch originally for another
comedian the nudge-nudge
yes was actually rejected mercifully by
Ronnie Barker because if you read it
it's not funny
there's no jokes in it but if you I
should Waffle gotta know my animal you
know and then it's kind of then it's
funnier Eric Idle wasn't born to comedy
at age 7 he was sent away to a royal
orphanage I my education was paid for by
the RAF because my dad was killed in the
RAF and every kid in my generation who
was there then none of them had any
fathers it was a fairly scary place
there was a dormitory a hundred yards
long and you were there twelve years
murder getting to hemorrhoid College out
of there is quite an achievement and
quite a difference yeah at Pembroke
College in Cambridge he quickly signed
up to perform in a college review the
very first piece of material I did was
written by John Cleese you know and
after the show he came over and I meant
it so my second term in Cambridge and
then my life changed after college he
teamed up with two other future pythons
in a comedy show I'm Terry Jones and I'm
King Lear I'm Eric Idle and I'm Edmund
I'm Michael Palin and I'm Cordelia their
success led to the offer of a bigger
show but the studio wasn't ready yet and
so when please call up said oh I've got
this offer for a late-night Sunday show
at the BBC will you want to come and do
it with me we said yeah we might as well
because we were waiting who waiting for
our big show to happen the big show
never happened and now for something
completely different
instead in October of 1969 Monty
Python's Flying Circus went on the air
you really didn't know what you were
doing I hadn't a clue but we knew what
we didn't want to do we knew we didn't
want to be save
now a frontal nudity
[Laughter]
[Music]
how is it received initially in britain
with massive indifference I wish to be a
complete forever man mainly I wish to
complete about this pellet what I
purchased not off an hour ago from this
very boutique oh yes the Norwegian blue
what's wrong with it I'll tell you
what's wrong with you it's dead that's
what's wrong but slowly word spread
eventually even to America where the
show debuted in 1974 the following year
Monty Python and the Holy Grail was the
highest-grossing British film in America
we're cooler to draw even George
Harrison declared himself a fan he
really came to your rescue at one point
he paid for the life of brian the movie
he mortgaged his house for the movie to
be made because he wanted to see it when
financing for the 1979 film collapsed
Harrison kicked in four million pounds
more than eight million dollars at the
time I was flabbergasted we were over
here looking for financing and people
would look at it like we're selling them
springtime for Hitler
you know Oh they've got a funny comedy
about religion okay show them that and
it was amazing really that he did that
the film's final crucifixion scene
featured a song written by idle though
wise look on
I love that song turned out to have a
much longer life than probably you
thought it it so did but about 13 years
later it suddenly became a hit in
England because all the football fans
would start singing it on the terraces
when they were losing oh why look on the
boy
sword of life da da da da there was a
real chanting that it is now the number
one most played song at funerals
British funerals yes I'm hoping to
conquer American funeral shortly in 2014
the surviving cast members of Monty
Python gave a farewell concert at the o2
arena in London so we got all these
singers and dancers to do all Python
songs otherwise it's like five
geriatrics you know it's like sitting
there doing sketches everybody knows how
did you feel about saying about it was
it was powerful it did feel like a good
a good way to say goodbye and a good
time to say goodbye but it's not quite
goodbye because money though all four
seasons are now on Netflix of Monty
Python's Flying Circus and Idol is
working on a film version of spamela and
it will never die because you have to
quote the Holy Grail whenever you can as
I did yes as often as possible we are
the Knights will say yes she taught me
that I did I did never seen the movie I
still remember when that show came on
the air in America and I was in college
you couldn't like the entire dorm floor
was on that was in the common room to
watch as we laughed during the interview
but